when you're cooking for a special
occasion you want to nail some key
things
one your recipes need to be bulletproof
you don't want a disaster on the big day
two
as well as tasting phenomenal they have
to be easy to serve so you can relax and
enjoy yourself three when you're out to
impress food needs to look great too
my first recipe fits the bill perfectly
stuffed lamb with spinach and pine nuts
stuffed meats are perfect for special
occasions they look impressive taste
amazing but more importantly they are so
simple to do
pan on for the stuffing
it's a saddle of lamb basically a sort
of rolls-royce cut perfectly shaped and
it suits stuffing to an absolute tea for
the stuffing finely chop an onion
garlic
nice thin slices
oil in
onions and garlic in
[Music]
salt
and pepper make sure the stuffing is
beautifully seasoned so it helps to
season the inside of the lamb
now we've got the color on those onions
we're gonna throw in some pine nuts and
that helps to give a bit of a texture
here's where it starts getting really
exciting
spinach in
and just lay the spinach over the pine
nuts it looks like a lot of spinach
that's going to condense and disappear
almost instantly
there's so much more flavor in spinach
when you saute it as opposed to steaming
it or boiling it gas off look at that
now to bring that together no eggs no
breadcrumbs
crumpled feta over the spinach
feta cheese adds a beautifully salty
sharp and creamy flavor
what this does
it brings that stuffing together
now
open up
the lamb
keep those little fillets to the side
that's the channel that we want to stuff
so i want to just open that up a little
bit there
salt
and pepper lightly
and before we put our stuffing in
we're going to season it with
sour
sumac is a wonderful lemony spice that
goes brilliantly with lamb and you can
get it in most big supermarkets and it
sort of cuts through that thick rich
sweetness of the lamb
open up that lamb there
take a spoon
if you're preparing this for the day
ahead then let the stuffing cool down
it's inevitable when you start rolling
it and tying it something's gonna
squeeze out so load up the ends
take these beauties these little fillets
and just support that stuffing and sort
of
increase that beautiful tunnel
and then from there
over
there
and bring that
towards you
and then roll
like i said
some of the stuff is going to come out
now
we've tied it first off
around the side
and don't worry about some flash
butcher's knot just tie it
one in the middle
you can get butcher string from your
local butcher or at cookware shops i got
two ties
go too thai it just forces all that
stuffing out of the lamb when it's in
the oven
nice
now we just season the top of it
the joint to make sure all the skin gets
seasoned
now you think normally that just goes in
the oven like that that's how my mum
would do it but
get your tray onto the gas oil in
it really nicely colored
none of your stuffing is coming out the
sides really important
look at that color beautiful it does
kick start the roasting process
gas off
into the oven
cook for 45 to 55 minutes depending on
how pink you want your lamb
lift the lamb out of the fat to rest
resting it raised up in the tin will
stop it cooking but not cool it down too
quickly and means you won't lose any of
those lovely juices
next i'm making a simple but
sophisticated accompaniment for the lamb
top and tell the cucumber
peel it
cut the cucumber
into three
and just core
taking out all that it's just sort of
watery seedy and
it spoils the flavor slice the cucumber
cucumber in really nice way of making a
cheap and cheerful cucumber look
glamorous we're gonna dress that
cucumber with a nice fresh yogurt couple
of tablespoons
next some fresh mint
dressing a touch of salt
a touch of pepper
and then pomegranate molasses
that just sweetens it up finish that
with lemon
mix that up
lamb it's rested
carefully take off the string
and then just gently pull them back
straightened edge knife that's going to
cut through that crispy fat on the
outside instantly i tied it purposely so
i can get
my portion control from the lines hold
it nice and firmly
look at your line where the string was
and look
this one is going to be amazing
lay and down
just in those two slices there it proves
that stuffing meat
is for special occasions because that is
a saddle of lamb at its absolute best
stuffing meats and fish not only makes
them look fantastic it also gives them
an extra added flavor dimension too once
you've mastered the technique you'll be
able to turn out dishes that will
guarantee you'll have an unforgettable
feast
my next recipe turns what used to be a
decidedly unfashionable cut off meat
into the star of the dish fit to grace
any table
slow roasted pork belly with fennel
[Music]
slow roasting works better on fattier
tougher and unfashionable cuts whether
it's a cheek or even a neck or this
amazing pork belly it's a fantastic way
to transform cheap cuts into amazing
melting perfection
take a very sharp knife
bring the pork belly towards you so
you're over and you've got all that
pressure and weight using the tip of the
knife i'm just sort of
nicking it and go across the pork belly
long strokes with a knife take your time
turn it
180.
this time what we're doing is just sort
of cutting those nice little sort of
diamonds but as that starts roasting on
top it starts getting nice and crispy
take
little handfuls of salt and just sort of
rub it in bend it over and in all those
cracks
really helps to get a nice crisp
crackling on top
roasting tray
getting really nice and hot
take a hole over fennel to intensify
flavor and to keep the meat succulent
i'm braising my pork belly with strong
vibrant spices and vegetables
crush and peel three whole cloves of
garlic and add to the fennel olive oil
in
fennel in
i like the
nice strong
aniseed flavor
that goes with that nice rich dense pork
fennel seeds
delicious
star anise
in
and just
a couple of cardamom seeds
and wow they're like little bangers like
little firecrackers incredible
lovely
fresh bay leaves
get your pork skin side down
just sear
the top of that fat that locks in all
that amazing flavor then i'm going to
flip it over and get it nice and crispy
and then i want fennel seeds embedded in
those little cracks
now
some white wine
the minute that white wine hits that pan
you can smell that light fragrance with
fennel
allow the wine to bubble away and reduce
until the alcohol has burnt off time
that the stock now the stock goes in
just underneath the skin so it roasts on
top all that meat under there will be
submerged because what happens in the
oven the top goes
crispy as anything
and the stock reduces and brazes at the
same time
really importantly bring that back up to
the ball before it goes in the oven
otherwise it will never boil never get
up to temperature
smells incredible
slow roast the pork belly at 180 degrees
for two and a half hours
[Music]
look at that
you've got that nice crispy skin on top
you can see how much of the stock
has evaporated
put that onto the board
it looks stunning
to make a delicious rustic sauce with
the flavour-packed contents of the
roasting tray first get rid of the
excess fat
take a couple of slices of bread it's
like a perfect sponge because you just
lay that
on top
and drag it almost like a net and it
just absorbs all that
fat if you want the perfect fried bread
trust me stick that in a frying pan
a nice teaspoon of mustard
whisk that in
and then simply simmer for a few minutes
before pouring into a serving jug
with your pork belly always use a nice
serrated edged knife
you can hear that
that
is amazing incredibly tender
that belly of pork is gonna almost melt
in your mouth you've got that sweet meat
under that crispy
belly of pork
what an amazing way to cook a very cheap
cut of meat
[Music]
so if a tired old recipe is getting you
down spice it up with fresh ideas and
flavors
my next recipe is an old classic roast
chicken but with a simple twist it takes
on a new life and it's guaranteed to
impress
one of the things i love about cooking
and that keeps me excited after 25 years
behind the stove is that there's always
something new to learn every day new
ingredients new techniques and new
cuisines start off with the stuffing
[Music]
it's amazing how exciting a stuffed
roast chicken can be because it keeps
the chicken incredibly moist and gives a
delicious texture inside the bird
i'm gonna start off with cured ceriso
this is a traditional spanish sausage
and it's
garlicky
spicy incredibly meaty
that gives a little bit of sort of
richness to the stuffing
get that cerezo in
start cooking that down and getting all
those oils out
a little touch of olive oil in there to
get it going right onions
chopped
add the onions to the cerezo and in a
matter of seconds they'll change color
as they soak up all the flavor
that lovely spiciness has been stolen
from that sausage now the onions smell
incredible
garlic
garlic
fresh thyme just hold it down and put
your fingers on there and it's a really
nice way of taking off all those nice
fragrant little time flowers
you can hear it crackling in the
background
these are cannellini beans
they're waxy
very soft
and so delicious but very dense
but for stuffing they're so robust
nothing breaks down
drain them off
in
they're going to take on all that juice
as well from this freezer i'm going to
season them now because they're very
dense so it needs some help
i mean that looks like it's
a dish on its own good enough to eat now
i want to sweeten things up a little bit
tomatoes half dried
in
that sweetens up
the stuffing
beautiful
the stuffing's ready look at the color
everything
looks spanish it looks delicious
now
stuffing the chicken i like taking off
these little knuckles
as the chicken cooks the skin stretches
over the bone you can get a really nice
drum and take off those little wingtips
as well
salt pepper
so important
now
you're stuffing
i'm going to go right inside the chicken
push it down this really helps to cook
the bird evenly because you're pushing
out all the empty spaces in the carcass
and take a nice large lemon
push the lemon in
pick up the parsley's nose pull the skin
over olive oil on top
salt
and pepper
a teaspoon of paprika
sprinkle it on and then get your hands
and sort of rub that in
let's see what the paprika is doing to
the chicken putting this like sweet
spicy marinade
it's not even roasted yet but it looks
delicious
[Music]
400 ml of white wine same quantity of
water that helps the chicken to steam
chicken in
be generous with the time sprigs
[Music]
make sure the fall is folded tightly
around the roasting tray so the chicken
steams in the oven keeping it moist and
juicy
into the oven
[Music]
cook for one hour at 180 degrees with a
foil on nice
take it out and remove the full lid then
give it another 30 minutes to crisp up
that skin
[Music]
look at that
it's so important to make sure you take
that tinfoil off with half an hour to go
beautiful
pierce that open
squeeze it in
that delicious gravy mix that into the
tray
and sieve that
that's really nice fragrant lemony
spiced roasting juices to finish
before we cut up the chicken take out
amazing stuffing
[Music]
incredible i'd have that with chicken
over potatoes any day
and then just get your
chicken roasting juices
now
to cut the chicken
up hold the drum
and slice straight through
and there's a wonderful
drum and the thigh through the wishbone
off
slice with the point at an angle so you
can see the texture
of that amazing roast chicken
just take my cooking juices just want to
give a really nice sort of lemony flavor
over my chicken and there you go
a delicious
very charming stuffed
roast chicken
[Music]
you